before we talk about your planning
reform proposals I'd just like to get
your reaction to What stilantis have
said overnight they effectively want the
UK government to renegotiate its brexit
deal
well I do think that we need a better
deal than the one that we've got
um I do think there are other things
that we need to do as well
um supply side
um chains Etc need to be improved so
there's a lot of things but is the
brexit deal we've got working well no it
isn't and we need to improve on that and
that's part of our plan to make brexit
work
so you will actually be looking to
renegotiate the brexit deal with the EU
yes we want a closer trading
relationship I think there's more work
we can do with the EU on science and
Innovation I also think there's more we
can do in the security space as well so
I think there are real improvements to
be made to the EU deal I don't think
many people look at that deal and think
it's working uh very well it was we're
promised to you know an oven ready deal
and um we got something which was
frankly Half Baked so there's a lot of
work to do there as there is on
everything else to improve on that clear
up the mess and then power our economy
forward because if there's one thing
that has been significantly bad over the
last 13 years or so it's our growth rate
our economy hasn't grown at the rate
that we need it to grow and that's why
I've said that an incoming labor
government if we're privileged enough to
be voted in will have as a central
Mission economic growth highest
sustained growth in the G7 and that
needs to be felt in living standards
Rising across the whole of the country
now the UK's trade performance has
deteriorated pretty badly since brexit
would you be open to going as far as
rejoining the EU single Market
no I don't think we should rejoin either
the EU generally or the single Market
but I do think that we should break down
barriers if you look at you know car
manufacturing is obviously in the news
today we've been a very good car
manufacturer for many many years we've
been good because the way that we've put
manufacturing together has been all of
the parts that are needed for the car
coming in as seamlessly as possible
arriving at the assembly point at just
the right time so that cars can then be
built turned around and out of the
warehouse as quickly as possible that's
a model of manufacturing that has worked
it has been impeded by the EU deal that
we've got and that's why we need to
improve on the deal I do think we can do
other things as well though I mean some
of those parts I think we should be
making in the UK so we're not constantly
bringing them on over borders so all of
this has to ladder up to a very strong
comprehensive plan to grow the economy
well let's talk about what you're
looking to do with the planning regime
as I understand it you are essentially
looking to loosen planning regulations
yes we want to build more houses
um you know as you all know many people
watching this will know the aspiration
the dream of owning your own home is
very real
um you know not least because for
working people it provides security that
they desperately need and that has been
killed effectively by the government
because whereas we had targets for house
building until the tail end of last year
those targets have been taken down uh
that means now the blockers are in
charge and house building will drop
probably to its lowest level since the
second world war so what I want to set
out today is what an incoming labor
government again if we're privileged
enough to be elected in we'll do about
that partly that's about putting those
targets back up but that on its own I
don't think we'll do enough we need to
get to grips with the planning framework
because at the moment it's those that
own the land and developers who
essentially choose how many houses and
where they're going to be I think we're
going to drive house building up at PACE
we need to put local areas in charge of
that so change the planning rules have
development corporations as vehicles on
the ground to drive building and make
sure that the the dream the aspiration
of owning your own home is realized for
so many people who at the moment have
had their dreams shattered and and you
know I I know when I was growing up my
dad was a tool maker working in Factory
my mom was a nurse we didn't have a lot
of money and sometimes we struggled with
our bills but we did have our own house
with a mortgage and that sense of
security so I never feared as a child
that we wouldn't have a roof over our
head our own roof over our head and
that's the sort of security that goes
alongside that aspiration to own your
own home now you've said in the recent
past you want to give communities more
say over developments in in their area
what if these communities don't want to
have their local Green Belt concreted
over
well on the
um basic principle the local area should
have a greater say I think that's really
important because at the moment as I say
land owners and developers tend to
choose warehouses are put and that often
leads to a conflict with local
communities whereas if local authorities
local areas had the had more of a say I
think it would actually reduce those
local conflicts you asked me about the
green belt of course we want to protect
our Countryside when we went on holiday
when I was a child we went to the Lake
District the countryside is rich is to
be protected but we are going to have to
make tough choices and there are parts
of the green belt where we build now and
I think there are better choices to be
made and the example I'd give just to
bring my argument alive if you like is
that there's been a housing development
in the southeast of England where the
choice for the Housing Development was a
playing field or a car park the car park
was technically in the green belt and so
protected
and so the playing field which was
technically outside the green belt was
chosen for the building so we've ended
up
um with a car park being protected and
the playing field being used to build
houses I just think that we've got to
make different choices so this is not
about disrespecting the need to protect
the green belt and the countryside of
course we've got to do that but we've
got to make tough choices about and if
you let local areas decide I'm pretty
sure they would say look if we had the
choice we'd have put those houses up on
the car park and save the playing field
that's that's common sense and it will
drive house building and that is also
part of our plan for rebuilding the
economy because for every hundred
thousand houses that we can build across
the United Kingdom then broadly speaking
that's one percent of GDP that goes up
that's desperately desperately needed
just at the moment
you're also talking about ending the
moratorium on onshore wind farms in
England what sort of veto will
communities have if they don't want
these things on their doorstep
well communities have to have a say but
at the moment the system is tilted so
that if only a few people object it
takes years to get anything done and
um what we're saying about planning on
housing applies frankly equally to other
business sectors whether it's wind farms
the Laboratories we desperately need the
warehouses we need all of the planning
is taking far far too long I asked one
of the energy CEOs if we're in
government how long would it take you to
build a wind farm and he said to me
about two years I said well why then
does it take 13 years or so now before
anything actually happens and they said
well it's two years to build it's about
five years for the planning and then the
grid which needs to connect to the wind
farm doesn't really crawl towards the
wind farm until the wind farm is
finished and you end up with 13 years
that's far too long and businesses
across the country Express their
frustrations time and again that the
whole thing takes too long and that
holds us back because other countries
are much more streamlined they've
changed their rules and they're winning
the race for the next generation of jobs
we have to take the tough decisions to
turn that around so that you know when
the question is asked you know which
nation is going to lead on wind turbines
which nation's going to lead on hydrogen
the answer is why not Britain
now staying with energy the unite Union
which is your biggest financial backer
has called today for the
renationalization of the entire UK
energy industry is that something you're
going to consider
well we have considered it and
um decided that it isn't the right step
and I'll tell you for why we looked at
it the summer before last when Energy
prices as you know went through the roof
and there was this question well
wouldn't it be better then to bring them
into some sort of public ownership and I
looked at it with my team and I said
well how much would it cost us to do it
and then the crucial question if we did
it would that reduce the prices which is
obviously the thing that's pressing on
people at the moment and the answer that
is no because even if you nationalized
brought it into public ownership energy
companies still have to buy on the
global market and that's why we did
consider it and in the end rejected it
as not actually answering the central
question which is how do you drive down
those Energy prices and I think there
are better things that we did it in
France
Energy prices
well I think it depends on the
configuration as to whether it's linked
to the producers of the oil and gas or
Renewables in the first place but the
the other things I think we could do is
we can Rush towards Renewables we do
believe that there should be a publicly
owned vehicle for that so that as we go
towards Renewables we want GB energy a
publicly owned company to be the vehicle
for ensuring that the proceeds of that
come back to the British taxpayer and
are used you know to help bring those
bills down so I'm not ideologically
opposed to something that's in public
hands in fact we're proposing GB energy
but that's to yield the future work that
we want to do there are other things by
the way I'm very very keen on the idea
that we properly insulate our homes if
we've been doing that for the last five
six seven years then millions of homes
would have very cheap bills I've seen
this you've probably seen it yourself in
places like Yorkshire where you go to
one of the homes that's been stripped
out in insulated properly and I went
there the people living there were
beaming from ear to ear on a freezing
February morning because their house was
warm their bills were very very low and
that ought to be not just what we expect
of new houses but what we expect to be
retrofitted to existing houses because
in the long run what we do with energy
bills you know we need to keep them down
there's been price freezes in place
they're very expensive things to do but
we've got to do the fix the fundamentals
if you like at the same time okay Before
I Let You Go you've obviously been on a
great mission to rekindle relationships
with businesses every CEO I know has met
either you or Rachel Reeves over the
last year or so can you carry your party
with you on that because you've even
been talking to private Equity
Executives which are for a lot of your
uh party uh a sort of uh folk devil
almost
yeah we've spoken to no end of CEOs and
um and I've changed my party and my
party now is fully signed up to this we
know that to grow the economy we have to
partner with business and when I say
we're pro-business what I mean by that
is that we recognize that business is a
Force for good that the next generation
of jobs secure jobs and output for this
country is with a active Dynamic
government if you like sleeves rolled up
working alongside businesses and that's
why the discussions we've had with CEOs
has not been just a cup of coffee get to
know you it's also been about how do we
work together in government and that's
why Rachel and I have met so many CEOs
we went to Davos as you may have seen to
speak directly to investors and to ask
you know what's the inhibitor why aren't
you investing in the UK in the way that
we think you should and a large part of
their answer was because we haven't got
the stability we haven't got the
partnership that we need from the
government at the moment and I'm
determined that we'll turn that round
and just as I've turned around my party
we want to turn around the country so
that we can drive forward to what I'm
absolutely convinced would be a better
future